last week i posted a reel featuring this
design in front of you today within a
few seconds it spiked with the youtube
algorithm and you guys absolutely loved
it so today i want to show you exactly
how i designed it and how you can
recreate the same in arcade arcade25
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
tomic and welcome back to the channel if
you're new here thank you so much for
joining me on this channel we talk all
things architecture and technology today
we're going over one of my favorite
alteration edition projects in the real
world yes this is 100 real project and
no i'm not going to be showing you
anything from the real project we're
just going to be recreating the actual
external elevation okay so like always
we start with the australian select
template because that is what is
available to me
you guys can use whatever is available
to you on the left hand side of my
screen i'm going to be having my
reference image which is this design
that we're talking about today and for
you it is basically going to be above me
slightly situated so you can always
reference back to it to see how the mind
works and what we're actually doing to
create something like this in the
existing reference image we're going to
start straight away by tapping control
and f7 to open up our ground settings
the first thing we want to do here is
change from first to ground ceiling and
then we're simply going to delete the
roof line because we don't need it we
only need 300 millimeters above and
simply inserting a layer below calling
it footings and going minus
172 will give us the overall totals that
we need so there isn't anything fancy
here it is a single story house with
just two different pitching gable roofs
that create the effect that we're going
for so we click ok
go delete stories we don't have to worry
about them too much so if we double
click on our footings layer and go to
our slab tool
so we can select our slab let's change
our slab generic to just the 250
millimeter with the timber finish it
doesn't really matter at this stage
we're going to be using this slab as our
guide so let's say we're looking at this
house left side left side
starting at the crosshairs intersection
zero zero we're going to draw our first
shape and that first shape is the
existing
sleeping quarters or the private section
of this house it's basically something
like a six meter by eight meter box so
if we type in eight meters tab button
six meters and press enter we will get
the foundation of what we see there on
the left now before we go any further
i'm going to click once select all of
these elevation section markers ctrl d
click again and just simply move them
out of the way because we don't need
them next i'm going to hold the alt
button clicking on that original slab
that we just drew then i'm going to
start by drawing that tunneling concrete
blade wall section so for me that is a
very long narrow section it's something
like two meters wide and let's call it
12 meters long i'm then going to click
on that go ctrl d and move it to the
front of our building go ctrl d again
holding shift tapping the d key
and i'm going to move it about two and a
half meters forward away from the
private sleeping quarters then i'm going
to repeat that same step for the public
open spaces that we see on the right
hand side so if i click this original
slab control d and then control again
clicking on a corner node dragging it
all the way across whilst holding shift
allows me to drag it 100 straight
clicking on the edge then clicking on
one of these edge lines here and going
offset edge if i drag it all the way
back i can see it's about eight meters
and realistically in this image it's
double if not even triple that original
space so let's just simply type in 24
minus
gives us basically that elongated shape
that we're looking at on the right hand
side that 24 meters is probably a bit of
an overkill so i'm just going to click
on it drag it back four meters and call
that 20 meters public eight meters
private with a two meter vertical
separation in the middle now i do know
that in real life this extends a little
bit further if not another two and a
half meters that way but we're not
really getting to see too much of that
elevation so it isn't too critical at
this point in time now if we come up to
our ground floor plan by double clicking
on ground right clicking on footings
showing as trace reference we can see
the underside of what we just drew for
those slabs
let's start with our wall tool change
our generic wall and i'm going to change
that to 270 mil block work
now those concrete walls can be concrete
they can be polished plaster they can be
a rendered finish they can be whatever
you want but for me personally in this
instance i'm going to make them a
rendered finish or polished plaster so
first things first let's zoom in to our
concrete pad for that vertical
separation holding shift clicking once
clicking ok to finish that series wall
and then repeating that same step there
clicking and holding shift at the same
time
allows us basically to create these
blade walls
now those blade walls are very different
heights and they are subject to the
height of our roof line so we will play
with them a little bit further a little
bit later down the track we just simply
want to get them in the position for now
now we want to come across to our wall
tool again change that wall section
let's go 90 mil block work because we
want to keep it the same blocks and
bricks all the way around so we don't
have to worry about it tapping the p key
to flip
that wall where we need it continuing it
all the way around
to our traced reference slab and then
once again repeating that same step on
the other side of the public spaces now
if we come into our 3d up the top we'll
see that we've started to create what is
basically the foundation of this house
our slab is a little bit low so if i
hold the shift button click on all three
command d or control d depending on what
system you're on
i can drag that all the way up to the
ground floor so it aligns properly with
where it needs to go if we come back
into our ground floor plan holding the
alt key allows me basically to select
this wall here now if we hold the alt
key we can basically copy this wall on
the left hand side holding the shift key
tapping p to flip it and simply aligning
it with the edge of our blade wall i'm
then going to click on that brick wall
ctrl d or command d clicking on one of
the edges
going all the way in holding shift
tapping the d key again to activate our
distance marker and i'm then going to go
two and a half meters minus so i have a
two and a half meter offset between
those two walls there is a false wall
here that basically connects those two
spaces so if i draw an additional wall
here by tapping the p button again to
flip that wall where it needs to go
selecting that wall we've just drawn
control d or command d
and pushing that back let's say one
meter for the time being
basically creates that false illusion of
wall at the same time this wall is
basically beefed up for no reason other
than to really give it that power and
structure so if i click once on the edge
hold shift tap d
300 and return it in we have our blade
wall that is for this side what i do
want to do now is select these two walls
go control m to mirror it then tap the
control button click on one of the nodes
and hold shift to mirror it perfectly
the other way and then control d allows
me to move it across
all the way to the edge of our other
blade wall now from memory i know that
space there is about six meters wide so
i can simply click ctrl d again and go
six meters to extend that all the way
clicking on our secondary wall dragging
all the way in
and coming back to 3d to see what we've
started to create so as you can see we
have our black max line cladding piers
on both sides here that basically
connect to our roof lines and then
intersect to the back of the house now
if we come back into our ground floor
plan we no longer need this section the
wall so i'm going to press alt g to
ungroup and click on the external node
and reconnect to the edge of that wall
over here is a private alfresco dining
isn't very deep at the moment it's only
about two and a half meters so what i'm
going to do is select that wall and once
again push that another 500 meters
select all three walls and control i
they really give us that emphasis of
depth in that alfresco dining then i'm
going to click on my footings layout
right click on ground floor show as
trace click on my slab click once again
and select insert new node i will align
the new node with the edge of my actual
external wall
clicking on the exterior line once more
and offsetting that edge to where it
needs to be i'll repeat that same step
for
this section of the house over here and
the private section of the sleeping
quarters as well so that way i have if i
come back to my 3d the extension of the
slab coming all the way through on all
sides coming back to our ground floor
plan i'm going to simply select this
wall and extend it all the way across
because that is roughly where my front
door is going to be my roof is going to
run back that way hide conceal and
disappear and my other two roofs are
basically going to connect off this
pitch all the way up and connect back to
the main space now if you're new to this
channel you probably haven't checked out
the links down below the first link in
the description is essential for every
single architecture student or anybody
in the architecture profession for that
matter it is a direct link to my website
that features the construction and
sketch design sketch list package which
is fundamental and pivotal for anybody
who is looking to start their career or
accelerate their career it is basically
a pdf checklist that you can go through
and check off every single page and
every single item so you know that for
sure whatever is going out of your
office into somebody else's hands is
going to be 100 correct so if we press
control up arrow we'll go to our ground
ceiling plan which is where we can start
creating a roof if we go to the roof
tool and then just using the generic
wall shell it's not that important we
are going to align it with the outside
of our brick leaf and tie that first
leaf all the way to the edge of our
concrete blade wall i'm going to select
the external side where i want it to
connect draw my first line click ok
and selecting that roof control m
mirrors it tap control to actually get a
duplicate holding shift flips it ctrl d
allows us to select that node and move
it very quickly and very easily now that
i have these two roof planes connected
what i can do is hold control on one of
these roof edges to automatically find
the perfect center if i repeat that same
step with this other side of the roof it
will automatically join those two rooves
together that is a really really handy
tip to know if you ever can't figure out
how those ribs align or where they
should intersect we come back now into
3d we'll see that we've started to
create what is the foundation of that
roof so if i hold shift and click on
both of those roof slabs i'll see that
it's a 22 degree pitch i'm going to bump
that up to about 30 degrees then select
my external wall hold
come down to stretch height go just past
the gable of the roof
right click on that wall
connect
solid element operations that wall is
automatically selected as a target i'm
then going to select the two rubs as the
operator select with an upwards
extrusion i do believe it's going to be
about 10 mil short so if i click execute
we'll see that most of that wall is
trimmed but not all of it so we'll
simply then select our roof extend it 32
millimeters past
and 32 millimeters past we'll do the
same thing on both edges i can close
that pallet and there is our first gable
roof on the left hand side which
basically allows us now to emulate how
tall this blade structure is going to be
so if i click on an external node go to
the top of that roof i know i want that
to be at least 500 millimeters higher
than that so let's type in five five
zero zero it'll bump that wall just past
that roof line
coming back into our ground ceiling i
can click on one of these rubs right
click command d
control button and intersect that with
the edge of our
external leaf again and then i can
extend that all the way in to our
secondary blade wall repeating the same
steps we did before control m tapping
control clicking on a node holding shift
control d and moving that to the edge of
our brick pier
then clicking on one roof holding
control clicking once reselect control
click again
we can now come into our 3d element
and visualize what we've done with that
secondary private space all of a sudden
that is starting to come together very
very quickly and very very easily
without us having to do an excessive
amount of work to actually make this as
architectural as we see in this example
image because i know this gable section
here of the roof is going to surpass
this significantly i'm going to draw
that in first so holding the alt key i'm
going to come to the edge of my external
leaf here and draw a nice big gable on
that side of the roof that goes all the
way up coming into 3d that blade wall
still too far for me so what i'm going
to do is come back into my ground
ceiling control down and then i'm going
to select all of these walls and that
roof i'm going to go command d and i'm
going to push that back two meters
then realign that wall with the edge of
our mass wall and realign that wall with
the same concrete blade wall coming back
into 3d let's see if we've managed to
articulate it a little bit better yes
it's definitely definitely coming back
together a bit more so we're going to
continue to lower this let's try 20
degrees which is almost perfect and if i
drop that one more degree let's call it
19 degrees that'll be a near perfect
connection at the top we would obviously
do that in actual roof pitching degrees
instead of just randomly selecting but
for the purposes of this knowing that
it's going to go everywhere around the
world there are all sorts of different
construction standards that it would be
just way too hard to get into so we're
just keeping things relatively generic
make sure that you apply your
construction guides your construction
knowledge and your industry regulations
to whatever you do design because what
you see on youtube doesn't mean it can
actually be built now that that little
bit is out of the way we can select this
secondary blade wall click on this here
and let's bump that up to about seven
meters i want to extend it just a little
bit more than what we had before i do
want to make this slightly higher so if
i select these two let's go 35 degrees
instead of 30 degrees and then continue
to increase this wall on the front of
the roof as well to about 23 degrees so
aligns like it needs to then i'm simply
going to come back into my ground floor
control up holding the alt key selecting
this gable roof that we've recently
created and duplicating it on this side
of the house coming back into 3d we'll
see we've quickly duplicated
that 24 degree roof on this side of the
house which allows us really to keep
creating keep going i'm going to select
both of these walls and extend them well
past
the gable roof above right click again
connect
solid element operations select our two
rooves add as operator subtract with
upwards and execute so now all we have
to do is basically adjust our roof shell
to make sure that it goes all the way to
the edge of our wall and trims off that
additional bit of roof coming back into
our ground floor by tapping control down
i don't want that to intersect the
easiest way without going into all
intersection priorities is backspace 0.9
and it will stop intersecting again
backspace one decimal down 0.9 and there
you go it will no longer intersect with
the side of that wall it does cause
headaches if you want to do it properly
you actually need to go through and
change the intersection priorities but
we're not worrying about that today i do
also want to extend these two walls up
past the roof and this front wall past
the roof as well so if i select all four
of those walls right click solid element
operations selecting our two rooves
adders operator upwards
execute
we finish off our design almost
perfectly without too many issues now
overall that the house has really
started to come together the only
element missing is this wall section
here so i'm going to go ctrl t to open
up those settings extend that one meter
higher so we get some depth some
grandeur in that space coming to my
ground floor hold alt and draw a new
wrapping roof
going all the way back to the end of the
house so going into 3d you'll see that
roofs been created going backwards at a
very steep slope control d allows us to
move it all the way to the top and i'm
simply just going to change that to say
three degrees so you cannot see it and
it disappears behind last but not least
there's only one wall that we've
forgotten about on the right hand side
that we didn't drag all the way past
and trim the roof shell to it so we're
quickly going to repeat the same
identical steps trim that roof shell and
finish off
the front of our architectural designed
home now as a quick little side note if
you're wondering why on earth this
design was actually created like it was
created basically the fundamental
architectural principles are an existing
dwelling here on the left hand side that
needed to be extended but it also needed
to be very thermally comfortable and
thermally broken
so the two concrete mass thermal walls
are basically going to radiate heat into
these two spaces especially this larger
public open space that is one grand void
with raking ceilings while still
allowing northern light through the
extended concrete blade on the right
hand side the main portal was actually
an extension of the floor plan it was a
living area that was extended further
out to create space as was the alfresco
here on the right hand side while the
left hand portal was basically a
mirrored image and an emulation only to
create architectural symmetry in the
balanced elevation however overall that
is the fundamental principles of why we
went with this design thermal mass
breaking the two public and private
spaces while hiding all of the services
all of the car yards everything behind
the design and driving all the way
around now we can start going into our
window design and what we did to
actually create this elevation there
isn't actually too much i won't go into
it too deep so let's go into our ground
floor plan let's go
window
and we're just going to drop a couple
random windows in here that we can come
back to and edit as we see fit in 3d so
i've placed five windows here i'm also
going to place one large door at the
front we're going to call it a nice big
hv grid door i'm going to place that
smack bang in the middle i'll adjust
that later as well and we also want a
nice sliding door so if we come back
into our window window settings type in
sliding we can find a basic sliding door
let's select this one here and click ok
there are two sliding doors identical to
each other in this design but they're
significantly larger we're just going to
place them there for the time being come
into 3d and actually start exploring
these windows in 3d so this window here
on the right hand side goes all the way
to the slab itself and it's
approximately two seven high so if we
type that in we'll get what we're
looking for extending it a little bit
further let's call that 1700 wide this
window here we're then simply going to
adjust it to the same height and reduce
it in overall height to 600 millimeters
there are two windows side by side there
i do remember there was an opening in
this space we're just going to leave
that blank for the time being now this
main window in the main portal at the
front we're going to click command t and
searching for a better window that is
more applicable to our situation which
is this double sash here command m to
flip it down the center where it needs
to be
and drag it into the position extending
it all the way out then pressing ctrl t
or command t
coming into our settings going to shape
changing that
uh to four five four six five five i
think it was roughly no tapping the m
key let's just measure that four nine
nine five so ctrl t again four nine nine
five
will get us exactly what we're looking
for there now looking at this design
further that roof can most likely be
dropped that 500 mil that we extended it
previously dropping that wall level two
to the underside
and extending this door all the way as
wide as it needs to be
and as tall as it needs to be as well so
make that a 2 7 door open up the
settings by going ctrl t
let's first of all change this orange
because i absolutely hate seeing orange
on the floor plans going to our hv grid
settings and changing our verticals from
three to two and from three to two as
well so we have a very simple clean
architectural door now we click ok on
that and we have our finished product
there for that door coming across to our
ground floor plan let let us extend
these sliding doors as wide as we need
let's call them three six hold alt alt
and control the same time
extends that all the way gives us nice
big sliding doors and then these two
windows i'm simply going to drag out and
shrink a little bit at the same time so
i'll make them 600 holding alt control
drops them all the way down so that's
basically a glass structure that we have
our image on the left if we click on
this find window over here we can go
into our dash options change our hv grid
to hv grid simply going 2 2
gives us an overall simple look and then
clicking ok
now i'm going to select all of my
windows at once right click ctrl t
change them from orange to black
and change my materials from stainless
steel or aluminium to black as well
i'll repeat that same step for these two
doors and that front door and then i'll
introduce a highlight window above that
door as well now the rest of the design
is very simple it is just materials and
claddings so if we select our two blade
walls command t
override all of our surfaces go concrete
let's change that to concrete 23 click
ok we have our first blade concrete
walls next we're going to select the
exterior edges of our house
and right click command t
then only the exterior needs to be
changed on this one let's go horizontal
pine for the time being go okay we have
our nice timber feature coming through
now i'm going to click on all of our
roof sections here go to my ci tools
covering roof covering will open up the
ci tools roof covering tool if you don't
have this you can get it through
archicad it is a subscription paid
plug-in but it is phenomenal and i
highly recommend it you can use any
other roof covering system as well or
mimic it in twin motion with material
but otherwise we are basically going to
click through go from our corrugated to
our ribbed
and we're going to just change some of
these settings so between a is going to
be 300 millimeters b is going to be nine
millimeters d is going to be 18
millimeters c is 50
and we're gonna call e 40 millimeters
for now that's absolutely fine i'm going
to click on my model override and i'm
going to paint that the same black color
clicking same with my floor plan
override all the colors straight black
okay and now we have our roof cladding
created we can come back into our ground
floor plan select all our walls alt g to
regroup to make selection a lot lot
easier select all the walls that we need
to basically create this cladding for
alt g and unclick those two walls there
ci tools coverings wall tool and we're
going to repeat the same steps we just
did for the roof but in reverse
so ribbed a in this instance is 50 b in
this instance is 18 c is 9 d is 300 and
e is 40
changing our materials and colors as we
require clicking ok making sure we align
with the outside of all of our wall
selections so that arcade knows where to
create those materials and that cladding
coming back into 3d
we can delete those two there we don't
need them and we can delete that front
door there as well we do not need that
finally all i'm missing here ci tools
covering roof covering just clicking
okay creates that same max line
wraparound roof and to change the actual
spacing here of what we see at the edge
ci tools covering
edit roof edges this side here needs to
be a barge not a junction okay and i can
see my framing coming through so command
t coming to framing let's just include
framing tick that off for the time being
and we lose our framing the only thing
missing from this design now is we'll
come into the ground floor plan go to
our beam draw a simple beam over here
tie that back into this wall and
introduce three or four columns on this
section here we will get what we're
trying to create on this side of the
page so if i was to
select both of these beams here change
them to a 120 by 35 millimeter extend
them to my ground ceiling call it two
seven instead of three click ok
select my three columns command t to
open them up 90 millimeter columns
absolutely fine ground connected to 2 7
okay
we have our roof connection there as
well so these beams here would most
likely be 300 deep and 350 even
basically just to hide the roof behind
it but overall that design is 100
completed the only thing we are missing
is the concrete stairs and the landscape
itself but that is all dependent on the
block the site and everything that you
are creating for but overall the
fundamental basic principles of this
design are 100 completed if you do want
a copy of this pln file that we've
created today it is linked down below by
the patreon link so if you jump onto
patreon sign up you can grab this pln
file and every other pln file i've
created on youtube and play around with
it mess around with it do whatever you
wish in your own time with this data
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed this tutorial i hope you
learned something new if you did make
sure you smash that subscribe button
down below and don't forget about the
like button believe it or not that like
button helps with the youtube algorithm
immensely so i'd truly appreciate it if
you smash that like button left to
comment down below what your favorite
part of this tutorial was and like
always i will see you next monday